Manos sobre nuestros corazones
nuestras frentes tocándose
nos comunicamos a través de movimientos y música
creando sentido del sinsentido.
Bella tiene 83 años y vive con demencia.
El baile nos da la oportunidad de encontrarnos.
¿Cómo aprendí a bailar con demencia?
Porque no soy un bailarín
Y no soy médico.
Pero interpreto a uno en el hospital.
(Risas)
Soy médico payaso.
O payaso médico.
Mis herramientas son cojines de ventosidades,
cascabeles,
(Cascabel agitándose)
y una nariz roja.
¿Conocen el viejo dicho: "la risa es la mejor medicina"?
Escucho eso un montón.
Al mismo tiempo, hay estudios que lo respaldan,
pero ahora mismo,
me gustaría llevarlos detrás de la nariz y más allá de la risa
y compartir cosas que vi pasando por unidades de cuidados intensivos.
En mis zapatones.
Talla 11.
Porque me tomo las payasadas médicas
muy, muy en serio.
(Sonido de pedorreta)
(Risas)
Mi mentor llevaba a cabo rondas de payasos en el hospital
cuando lo abordó una enfermera.
Tenía que intubar a un niño por la nariz.
El niño no quería,
así que, en lugar de sujetarlo,
le pidieron a mi colega que si podía ayudar.
Así que el payaso pidió un segundo tubo
y se lo metió en la nariz.
De esta manera.
Y por favor, no hagan esto en casa.
(Risas)
Bien, el niño vio esto,
agarró su propio tubo
y rápidamente se lo metió por la nariz,
de esta manera.
(Aplausos)
Los payasos, la enfermera y el paciente
descubrieron juntos una solución creativa para su situación.
Y adivinen qué, hay evidencia científica que lo respalda.
Ensayos controlados aleatorios en Israel y en Italia
mostraron que los payasos pueden ser tan efectivos
como los tranquilizantes, pero sin efectos secundarios.
En 2004 comencé a realizar mis propias rondas de payaso
en el Centro de Cáncer Memorial Sloan Kettering en Nueva York.
A mi colega y a mí nos invitaron a acompañar a un joven de 6 años
con el acento sureño más adorable
mientras se purgaba su puerto de quimioterapia,
un procedimiento muy incómodo y habitual.
Nos unimos a él, a su madre y a su enfermera
en este cubículo pequeño, cerrado con cortinas.
Cada encuentro con payasos médicos empieza con el consentimiento
del paciente.
Así que le preguntamos si podíamos estar allí.
Él dijo: "Claro".
A menudo somos lo único que un niño puede controlar
mientras está en el hospital.
Empezamos con un truco de cartas,
extendí la baraja para que pudiera elegir.
Pero cuando la enfermera se acercó con la aguja
para limpiar el puerto,
comenzó a gritar y maldecir
como no había oído jamás a ningún niño de 6 años.
Entonces dijimos: "¿Volvemos más tarde?".
Él para, con la boca abierta,
ojos húmedos con lágrimas, cara roja por la ira,
y sonríe:
"No, está bien, quiero que se queden aquí".
De acuerdo.
Empezamos a tocar una canción.
mi colega con la flauta, yo con el cojín de ventosidades.
La enfermera se acerca con la aguja,
y ocurre de nuevo, este torrente de palabras malsonantes.
Él pasa de jugar y reír
a gritar y llorar,
ida y vuelta hasta completar el procedimiento.
Por primera vez,
experimenté una extraña dualidad entre alegría y sufrimiento.
Pero no por última vez.
Cuando estamos allí, no estamos solo para distraer
o hacer que alguien se sienta mejor.
Los payasos médicos trabajan en cada momento
para crear conexiones entre los payasos,
la enfermera, los padres y el niño.
Esto proporciona una fuente de poder y control al niño
mientras apoya al personal con su trabajo.
He pasado más de una década trayendo alegría y deleite
a las camas de niños con enfermedades terminales
en los mejores hospitales de Nueva York
¿Y saben qué he aprendido?
Todos están sufriendo.
Personal, familia, pacientes.
Los pacientes en el hospital porque están sufriendo.
La familia sufre mientras navega por la incertidumbre, dolor
y la carga financiera del tratamiento.
El personal sufre, pero más de agotamiento.
Más y más profesionales de la salud
denuncian sentirse sobrecargados y extenuados.
No soy tan ingenuo como para sugerir
que la solución sea enviar payasos.
(Risas)
Pero ¿y si...?
¿Y si las herramientas de los practicantes de payasos médicos del mundo
impregnaran todo nuestro sistema de salud?
En 2018 en el Encuentro internacional de Payasos Médicos,
había más de 150 programas en 50 países diferentes.
La universidad de Haifa
ofrece un programa formal de licenciatura en payaso médico.
Argentina ha aprobado leyes que requieren la presencia de payasos médicos
en hospitales públicos de sus provincias más grandes.
Y este trabajo afecta más que los pacientes
Mejora las cosas para todo el equipo médico.
Uno de mis juegos favoritos en el hospital
es la música de ascensor.
Me encantan los ascensores, porque son un lugar
donde se cruzan caminos, se encuentran diferentes mundos.
Es íntimo,
incómodamente tranquilo
y solo ruegas por un poco de interrupción juguetona.
Las puertas se cierran
y "The Girl from Ipanema" empieza a sonar en el órgano Hammond
porque guardo un altavoz portátil escondido en mi bolsillo.
Para aquellos acostumbrados a usar el ascensor silencioso y estéril
es un momento de sorpresa.
La gente tiene permiso para aceptar o no esta interrupción.
El juego crece con cada parada,
porque tan pronto como el ascensor se detiene,
la música para.
Nuevos pasajeros se suben
y los actuales pasajeros pueden presenciar a los nuevos pasajeros,
su sorpresa, ya que escuchan la música de ascensor por primera vez.
Experimentas el cambio de adultos
de pie en silencio, extraños en un ascensor
intentando reprimir su alegría,
a "¿Es una fiesta o un ascensor?",
llena de carcajadas.
Una investigación realizada en Brasil,
Australia, Canadá y Alemania
confirma que las intervenciones artísticas de payasos médicos
mejoran el ambiente laboral para el personal, más allá del ascensor,
y apoyan su trabajo gestionando el cuidado.
Una prometedora investigación en EE. UU. sugiere
que incorporar arte en el hospital
puede mejorar el ambiente de trabajo
dando mayor satisfacción laboral
y una mejor calidad en la atención.
Mi trabajo me ha enseñado
cómo estar de verdad en el presente.
Cómo respirar en una habitación con una persona con dolor.
Cómo conectar
construir confianza, no importa la edad, capacidad o enfermedad.
Y cómo el payaso médico es una excelente forma de usar el arte
para devolver la atención a la atención médica.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)